he took tuesday edition of pft ot chris
sims mike florio some things that we
either didn't get to during pft live or
that we'd like to expand upon and chris
you were making some excellent points
about the supply of minority coaches in
today's nfl nepotism cronyism
uh that goes a long way toward
limiting the number of opportunities at
the entry level as guys
start their careers as guys get into the
pipeline from which they possibly can
emerge as a coaching candidate you you
are there working alongside others you
learn the ropes you stand out you get
groomed if you're not in that group of
young coaches who are trying to work
their way up the ladder you're never
going to work your way up the ladder you
have another angle to this that i think
is very important you've raised it in
the past but i think it's worth
reiterating now as we try to understand
why it is
that so many of the guys in the pipeline
are
uh not minority candidates they are
white young coaches who are in a
position to be groomed to become future
head coaches yeah well it's it's almost
a little bit like a closed secret
society and you know again i i want to
make it clear it's not about like you
know it's not like white coaches are
like oh we don't want to hire black
people or do anything like that it's not
like based in racism it's just
based in a you know long-rooted culture
of people who have been in the
profession and then the sport has become
also so popular that anybody who knows
anybody that's connected to the sport is
trying to get a job or trying to get
their son or their grandson you know in
a building somewhere to be a part of a
football organization let alone the
family connections like we've talked
about i mean hey listen we could go
almost to every team in the nfl and i
could show you a coach and go his dad
was a coach i mean hey sean mcvay but
you know it's he's got relations of
course kyle shanahan wade phillips jason
garrett i mean that we can just keep
going on and on with this conversation
but i think the other big issue here to
me
uh with the minority coaching and and
not getting enough at the entry level
african-american people there
you know to like you said come up the
ranks within an organization really get
to see all facts and facets and be
groomed that way the other issue is the
money they play to these low-level
employees within an organization and you
know to me a lot of people might sit
there and go what's that have to do with
anything well i'll tell you what it has
to do with something the pay is so
little okay that if you don't if you
don't come from a family with money
you're almost not capable of supporting
yourself or a life or if you have a
young family forget about it you know
mike i i made less than minimum wage
with the new england patriots there's no
doubt about that i mean there's no doubt
i was working over a hundred hours a
week i made like you know ten thousand
dollars for the year after taxes that's
what i made as a low-level entry guy now
thank god i had made money playing
football and i came from you know phil
sims and he could have helped me out if
i needed it or whatever it may have been
too but that's part of the culture too
that we see and it's very hard if you're
kind of a hey i didn't come from a
family with money i don't have a mom or
a dad or a grandparents that can support
me that way
you it's hard to make it all work in
those low-level entry positions and
that's also the other benefit of yes you
know the connections if your dad knows
the owner or your dad as a coach or
whatever it may be you have the cushion
to be able to withstand those type of
years
yeah and you know this is part of the
culture
of professional sports i assume it
happens in other sports as well the idea
that
you prove that you love it you prove
that you're determined you prove that
you're not in it just for the money
because you're not getting any money
you're doing it basically for free right
you you are living in some fleabag
apartment somewhere if you don't have
the money uh otherwise to subsidize your
lifestyle well it's okay if you're
single but if you have a family that
isn't gonna fly there's a point where it
becomes irresponsible you got to go find
a job that's going to put more
money in the bank account more food on
the table to take better care of your
family so it does what it does
is
it restricts the universe of those
entry-level jobs to
young
single and or
independently wealthy individuals and um
it it it it adds to the barriers i agree
with you right uh it adds to the
barriers for people who
aren't in a position to say i'm going to
go sign on
to this career to this lifestyle with no
guarantee it's ever going to go anywhere
and i'm going to make jack squat for the
next several years and you know what
maybe the maybe the discussion should be
how about paying a living wage to these
folks at the low end of the of the
spectrum right
clearly the money's there
wha what what the hell is this 10 000
after taxes right let's take better care
of these people who are coming in and
trying to compete and show and prove
that they can contribute i mean
it's it doesn't have to be a badge of
honor that they're doing it for peanuts
there's other ways to prove their value
working essentially for nothing does not
prove that much more value than the work
that you do once you're in the door it
really is kind of amazing to me that
that's the culture and that's not to
pick on the patriots every team does it
it's an industry-wide reality it's a
phenomenon and it's all rooted in this
idea of you prove that you love it by
doing it well there are plenty of people
out there who love it who can't do it
because they have responsibilities of
their families and they don't have
somebody else that's going to subsidize
their lifestyle when they're working for
nothing
right or added to the fact that there's
others out there that like along the
lines of what you're saying who are more
qualified to work in an nfl front office
or a coaching staff but they don't have
the proper connections or know the right
people and that's where i also get into
the all-nfl right now where it's more
political than ever because of its
popularity and you know just again you
know just walking around facilities
knowing people whatever it may be there
is plenty of people that are in that
building with you know how did you get
here and it's not about oh i have this
track record and i worked here here and
here to get here no i got here because
my dad knows the head coach my dad knows
the owner my dad knows the gm
you know my grandfather's really good
friends with the owner whatever it may
be and then they get to be
uh yes put in a building get a job and
mike to further your point too you know
with the money and the situation there
you know usually it takes a little while
for you to climb the ranks when you get
that first entry-level job in the nfl
yeah they're going to make you earn your
stripes and then even if you do get a
little bump up to the next step it's not
much more if you're like you're going to
finally sit back in your recliner big
i made it they're paying me the big
bucks now no now you're just barely
getting enough so you have to almost be
able to withstand
breaking even financially for about four
five six years in some cases before you
startling just finally start to make
money to go hey you know what i can
finally marry my girlfriend and actually
have the kid we've been talking about
because i haven't been comfortable in
popping the question because i knew i
wasn't going to be able to support her
or
a family type lifestyle so it's an
institutional issue that the nfl needs
to work on certainly
and and i think it's i look i've never
seen it really come up before as part of
the discourse but i tell you as soon as
we get the and to take people behind the
curtain a little bit
at some point after the show we get a
little code that we can drop into a
story at profootballtalk.com so you can
see and hear this video once i get that
code i'm going to write a story and i'm
gonna put this code in there and i'm
gonna hopefully get the attention of the
owners who will be multitasking today
while they are doing the virtual annual
meeting that has been postponed from
march till now we all know that they
come to i know i know for a lot of
people out there like oh owners read
your site yes they do and hopefully
they'll see this and they'll start to
understand maybe there's a better way to
staff the lower levels of the front
office and the coaching staff so that
people
do have
an opportunity to earn the kind of money
that can take care of a family because
you're walling off potentially great
candidates there are people out there
who could be the next vince lombardi who
never get into the coaching profession
because they got married young and they
have kids that they have to take care of
and it's irresponsible for them to make
nothing while they pursue this dream
yeah yeah that's exactly it and that's
bs
you know as far as what america's built
on and everything like that you know and
the nfl's gonna claim america and do all
that then you know hey let people live
the american dream with nfl football so
i think that's very real mike and hey
the one thing i said during the show and
i'll stand by i'd like to see them you
know tick for tack do this at low level
entry jobs in the nfl hey we signed a
white assistant right one year in the
scouting department as white scouting i
said next year you gotta sign a black
one then yeah or or if it's you know two
in one year one has to be white one has
to be black oh a low-level coaching
assistant quality control hey last year
we got a white guy this year you got to
get someone young and and
african-american to me that's where it's
going to start those at the root level
there and to what you have said it's
going to help you know
let some of these these african-american
coaches be groomed understand
organizations from top to bottom
and really understand the intricacies of
what makes them special and then they
have a chance to succeed aka brian
flores aka
mike tomlin those are what those guys
did they were fortunate enough i don't
know how they got those jobs but they
got in the building and they made it
work and they certainly have proved
everybody that they are qualified smart
and understand how to run a football
team
and let me just suggest a different
approach because i'd like to use a
one-for-one type of a thing as the
absolute last resort i'd like to address
the more the more fundamental issues
that are causing the problem to see if
that makes a difference improve the pay
of the lower level employees in nfl
organizations and also get rid of the
cronyism system i know it's a lot easier
for hr people to fill open jobs if you
know the accountant's grandson
is is interested in getting into
football and and uh this person checks
all the boxes and meets all the basic
criteria
no we're not going to go the easy way
we're not going to placate a sponsor or
placate somebody we have a relationship
with we're going to do a full and open
search we're going to take the time to
do it we're going to find the best
person for the job period and it doesn't
matter right having an in isn't going to
matter anymore now look easier said than
done much easier said than done but this
is part of the commitment that i think
teams need to make if they want to truly
improve the situation without some of
these artificial measures that are just
going to piss a lot of people off and
anytime we talk about quotas or programs
that are essentially affirmative action
which is what this coaching gm proposal
is uh yeah the more that you do that the
more you stir resentment and the more
you undermine the people who get the
jobs i'm more in favor of creating
ways where it organically and naturally
happens that there's a more diverse
group of people who get these jobs and
uh i think i i think i think we've
touched on some i think maybe
people out there who
actually are in position to affect
positive change can at least consider
before they flat out ignore what we have
to say that's okay yeah we're used to it
we'll be back on wednesday with more pft
live more pftot there's a new chris sims
unbutton coming up later today check us
out around the clock at
profootballtalk.com everyone enjoy your
tuesday stay safe we'll see you tomorrow
see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports